I think it's like losing Ted Healy from
the Three Stooges it's not a big loss
Ted Healy get sick it's a I love getting
a Ted huge okay nobody's gonna get it I
don't care I'm just like I'm gonna get
it in there the stooge fans will get it
but back so uses a teleportation device
to beam shredder away resulting in him
somehow meeting up with everybody's
favorite alien brain Krang just bring it
in a song sequence my kid no no that's
not the reason good we'll try another
one gonna be ready ruled no no no that's
not wrong no no rock solid rock steady
I'm rock steady yeah rule no no that is
I'm sorry
no rock steady the big reason is his
voice good I'll try one more wrong the
big issue is his boy wasn't ready for it
all right
okay hmm don't be wrong the big issue
look at Vegas a wrong you're like double
rule that's D critic comes back again
you wanna switch yeah we're filming mom
mom do the roaches were making her
videos go Tom Bailey develop the most
awesome character and I'm gonna return
to us oh god I am so excited because a
woman in a pantsuit will balance out a
woman in a short skirt good
hey we're great for black people and
transformers to know if Tyrese is yo
positive he's really off the rails and
the original film he's beating the shit
out of bad guys but here he's throwing
CDs CDs nuts but of course wrong hey
Timon time to make our obligatory cock
joke
Pumbaa not in front of the kids God is
that better than I am I always thought
like splinters Alire like you like when
I was a kid I was just like why is one
of them Billy early Splinter is the
leader but I'm old you know you be
second semester yeah yeah I guess he's
just the one who trained him your
Splinter to here yeah even though he
saved him in the Turtles yeah he saved
him the sudden like yeah I was just
hanging
through most of the film and I somehow
save you guys I talk to you through fire
you can even hold you look in the mire I
mean how could you not fuck I even came
up with Cowabunga Turtles kind of salty
movie yeah Leonard did everything was a
splitter movie let's just do that like
like a han Solo movie that's like the
early years of Splinter he's adorable
when he's happy do you want bottle them
up and Somali I do I really feel you
know what you know what he just gagging
no way how much you forget to say it I
want to bottle him up you want to put
that out there he's adorable and he's
happy
oh you know I've been drinking Bailey's
all right oh yeah oh sorry
what still yeah this is seafoam oh you
do more like a cross like that yeah
all right yes boom like you know it okay
all right like that yeah there you go
that's it wait Seidel this way clearly I
did a lot of fights